you nate there's a shoe in way to help
our homeless community
this season the las vegas fashion
council and the southern nevada byrne
foundation
have teamed up for their very first
flip-flop drive rocky is live at a local
fire station to get the details
hey guys yeah it's perfect that we're
coming up right after excessive weather
warnings because this is why
we are giving flip-flops to the homeless
so on behalf of channel 8
and jc fernandez thank you for your
donation the burn foundation and the
las vegas fashion council let's go ahead
and make our donation
at station 29 it is official all right
the
flip flop drive the first ever flip-flop
drive is underway keith your slogan is
every flip-flop has a story what does
that mean and why are you doing this
good afternoon my name is keith
armington and yes
every flip-flop has a story because
every bare feet has a story
everybody walks on them especially with
this seat that we have out here today
110 degree weather
it's hot out there and we all know what
happens during the summer and 110
outside but
our firefighters here said it's actually
150 on the ground
correct in a 150 degree ground ground
temperature
people's feet can burn just like that
just super quick and it's it's a mess
and why is it so important to give back
flip-flops to our homeless community
obviously they're outside without a home
and they need it the most that's correct
i mean our homeless population is it's
out there it's it's full force
nowadays nowadays and with the
temperature that we have going on right
now
they're not going to express need for
help they're just going to go on
throughout their day and
when they burn their feet they're not
going to ask for their help they're not
going to go to the hospitals
so after a burn with them it gets worse
i mean they don't have a home they don't
shelter all they have is the sun and
it's brutal on them
well i'm so glad that they have this
community as well because this is such a
great effort and
las vegas fashion council carrie tell us
how you guys are involved
yeah so the las vegas fashion council we
partner with a different non-profit
every month
and we were presented the opportunity to
partner with the
southern nevada burn foundation we
thought it was a perfect opportunity
to give back to our community support a
wonderful organization
and throw in a little fashion component
with it as well with flip-flops
so we're thrilled that this is our first
annual
collaboration we look forward to doing
this every single year with the
foundation
and our goal currently is about 800 pair
i think we've actually already met that
but don't tell too many people because
we still want more flip flops to
continue to come in
exactly thank you so much carrie alright
head to the burn foundation's website
to find out what locations you can
donate at thank you guys for everything
you do i'll send it back to you